hi it's me ross matthews and guess what
it's bring your fiance to work day
because dr wellington garcia my man is
here we debuted exclusively the new
cover of the knot magazine with who is
that what's his name again maha's been
to be yeah that one it on the cover
wellington and i have um a spread inside
celebrating our upcoming nuptials very
exciting day and while we were here we
thought we'd play around in the uh
digital studio you down oh my god so
excited okay do this let's hit it
[Music]
what do you think
okay
yeah
he booked the travel but i would plan it
i do
i'm a natural beauty so
can we call this off
the whole thing
that would be me but i'm never really
late i just always think i'm gonna be
early right you just don't know how
traffic in new york actually works yeah
but i'm rarely late i just don't
yeah it's me
[Music]
hello hello recipes it's a recipe
thank you sell it
thank you
[Music]
can we share this one i mean that's the
beauty of like
gay
relationships yeah double your wardrobe
so yeah
i know it really i can't recommend it
enough we even wear the same shoe size
yeah yeah and we we rarely spend time in
the closet anymore but
we
now we have a lot of clothes in there
[Music]
that's him i'm a good reservation maker
yeah we're going to dinner tonight and
uh you want to know where
yeah so would i i don't know where
because
surprise
[Music]
neither
we wake up we are we are like active
senior citizens we are up at like well
there's a five in front of it 5 30.
[Music]
oh our tastes are so difficult i think i
make a great playlist but he'd be like
i've never heard this song in my life
and i'll be like it's donna summer and
he'll be like who's that
uh you do the same i you know try to get
you some hip-hop stuff and you're like
say that again yeah i i don't know the
hip-hop so much
[Music]
me me me me me me
i'm excited
i love you love you
that's my man
[Music]